it wasn't clean
actually nowhere close to it but
you know it's still something
um
what is this
i thought these lines in general were
better for white but
maybe it has some concrete idea
where do you go knight e4 or knight a4
i think you go knight a4
yeah both both players cameras would be
nice indeed
don't know
um i don't know how to do that
and i actually set up the stream myself
today that's why
that's why those things are not
happening
um i don't know why he's playing this
land because generally white is just a
little bit better
and i'm generally happy to
to play endings against him
that d4 roxy one there's not a three
queen of three queen e7 maybe the queen
e3
looks a little bit better
oh he checks first yeah so i should
probably
bishop b5
bishop d7 queen e2 am i not a little bit
better there
i think i am
it's queen e4 i can take the bishop e3
and
this king would not feel safe in the
center i would i would think
queen before king of one
yeah the king unless he can exchange
queens
quickly then his king is going to be in
a lot of trouble
i don't really see it 95 i got rook d1
so he gives a check just gonna sidestep
with the king
this king is a lot less safe than this
one
so i think this is
um this is very good for me yeah
obviously if daniel wanted to do this he
would be great
since he's got he's got oodles of
charisma and an entertaining style
and as well as being extremely strong
can i take this b6
a3 i don't know queen of five rook d1
starts walking this way
i probably shouldn't
let's maybe go rook c1 instead make sure
his king doesn't run away
next i probably want h4 rook h3 to
develop
oh he's wearing the balenciaga shirt he
always wears
that is shocking
oh so he's intending this i missed that
maybe i haven't played this very
precisely then
let's go a3
for more for lack of alternatives than
anything else
queen a4 yeah what
maybe there was nothing special but i
feel like i could have gotten something
more
for the lack of alternatives let's grab
a pawn
so i'm taking then grabbing
d8 and a7
but i feel like you should be able to
equalize here somehow
with concrete play
probably starting with b6 i would guess
then bishop b8 escaping with the bishop
rook c6 maybe
yeah let's go g3
maybe not
g3924 it's annoying oh this one
no i think i have chances so bishop gets
here
then it's attacking b6 and defending f2
d7 okay let's go king g2
i don't know what king d7 was all about
think i'm consolidating now he will get
a good knight on
ge4 so it won't be or e4 but it so it
won't be
easy to convert but i'm
clearly much much better now
can you have three
it's not so easy to untangle maybe
rook d3 maybe not
not sure this move does a whole lot but
it's a move yeah i wanted
probably should go back and then root b3
yeah no root b3 and there's no fork
now i think i'm making some progress
let's try and stymie his pawns test him
a little bit
oh i thought he would go to e4 now i
think i'm just
i'm probably just winning
okay not easy still
oh that was close i'm very close to
flagging there
very close okay gotta play a lot faster
this is tense very very tense
check
bring the king finally
oh there's a fork it's bad news
okay
now now i'm
everything's protected and i should be
should be winning
quite comfortably bishop d4
let's do a check
take a pawn
let's see two i got ka2
there should be six now check i start
going with the king again
okay c4 rook b6 yeah this doesn't work
and the pawn queens wow
i didn't have